yo han lava slips into his white crooks
jacket at this time he's not heading for
the kitchen on her skis the Austrian is
preparing to square off against
colleagues on an unaccustomed terrain
she can keep of course everyone here has
ambition someone with no ambition might
as well be dead you have to show your
best side everyone's watching to see
what laugher doesn't wondering if you
can ski as well as could be fun he's got
the will that does he have the skill
might be happy if I were already at the
bottom when I look down I have the
feeling cooking is easier Johan Martha
is competing in the culinary world cup
against about 100 other top cooks from
the german-speaking world many of them
have restaurants in winter sports
resorts and today they're competing for
fractions of a second the way they would
to win Michelin stars there's my daddy
been putting effort into it that's like
cooking just like in cooking you can't
start simply coasting that's not a novel
as disclosed in my cooking's a team
sport the whole team has to pull
together and here you go out to the
starting line and you're alone until you
reach the finishing line it is then you
have lots of friends again it's like
you're a blogger great site go go go
Johan lava is slower than most of the
other skiing cooks but he'll have a
second chance in the cooking part of the
competition
here lava heads a team of six cooks
they'll have to prepare a meal from
ingredients assigned to them this is the
first time I've had a feeling that too
many cooks spoil the broth but we're
good we'll manage your comp is not
complicated at all we have two stars so
everything's fine you n half only has 10
minutes before his filet and champagne
sauce has to be presented to the jury
skiing legends like martyred early and
German TV stars like yohannes bacana and
Marcel rife charge the dish more
impressed they conjure up an entire meal
in just 10 minutes so why does it take
so long in a restaurant they're all so
long at office parkour skipper it was
only briefly cooked but delicious a good
piece of meat vocaloid whether that's
enough to win the competition will be
revealed at the gala celebration in the
evening Martin zebra chef at a luxury
hotel and ish girl is preparing the meal
for it the centerpiece of one course is
lobster yo han lafa looks over his
shoulder to test what's in store for the
evening offending me Arthur if I had to
I could cook something myself but to be
honest I don't want to stand here and
cook for 350 people of whom 120 to 150
think they're the world's best chefs
seen Alice T best chefs teaser editor
dismiss my hunter Lee's army this that's
why I admire his courage is any mood so
as I have you can I have a taste it's
like it used to be a court I'm the food
taster who screens for poison oak you
could as well I'd eat it you like the
slight sweetness of the corn with a
slight sweetness of the lobster it's
very harmonious and then this popcorn to
accompany it Tanya
the lobster is the prelude to the great
garla of the competition the cooks enjoy
it but one member of the culinary jury
has a quibble
a llamado I'd say I don't need to have
popcorn with it I'm concentrating on the
lobster and it's very good then comes
the award ceremony in skiing the winner
is cooled off Ubar of Austria as in
years past in the cooking part human
lavas team comes in a close second after
hunts houses team up I get it actually I
thought we would win because our meat
was just fantastic and the source but
there are often juries who don't know
what they're doing and there's nothing
you can do but it's nice to have got
away from my daily routine and done
something else I'm motivated it was fun
and now i'm looking forward is a decent
cooking again the first it's time to
celebrate and a chance to talk shop with
other top chefs is even more important
for your home life than winning the
culinary world cup
you
you